the next thing I want to talk about is
this notion it's called convolution
which uh it's quite fundamental notion
in Fourier analysis it comes up a lot if
you do if you use free analysis to prove
things in additive combinatorics which
is something I think we'll see
maybe sometimes in this program
considering the new breakthrough and the
three terms of my progression so
okay so what is the convolution uh if I
have two functions it's an operator
binary operator so if you have two
functions on my group I can Define I'll
Define their convolution
which is another function that goes from
G to C as defined as the polynomial so
it Maps X to
um expected value
and G
of x minus y gly
and you can do a change of variable and
you can write this also as
expected value over Z so if we call this
sync Z so it becomes
F of z g of x minus Z
um so because of that it's uh
commutative
doesn't matter the order doesn't matter
okay and uh why is it useful uh
for us please and comment I can describe
discrete applications one nice thing
about it is that you can do things like
that so let's say
let's say my group is
so it's Z2 to the n
and I have a function f here
again say to R and now
suppose I wanna
for every point x I want to average the
function over say Hamming ball of radius
R around X
so this is say R so Hamming ball
foreign
so I want X to be mapped to
average of
let's say
if a y where Y is selected this Hamming
ball of radius R around the point x okay
something like that and you can easily
represent these kind of things with
convolution and study them
that way
uh
so why
so generally let's say that a be a
subset of G
and
suppose I want to look at the function
that Maps X to this thing that you
select a point from some from the set a
at random
and then you look at the uh of
X Plus y or let's say minus y to be nice
with convolution
right so if I take a to be say now the
Hamming ball of radius R around zero I'm
gonna get this thing that I want because
uh it's going to be x minus something
that's chosen from that Hamming ball so
it's going to be around point x right so
I'm just changing the center so uh
so how do I represent this with
convolution I can Define this
thing mu of a so this Maps every point Y
to
this there's this normalization Factor G
size of a and then whether the point is
so this is the indicator function of the
set a it is one if Y is an A and zero
otherwise
now with this notation I can now write
um
G
so now G is really just going to be f
convolved with this mu a so this is
something that's uh
one does a lot in other combinatorics
for example uh yeah when you want to
average over another step you define
these measures
and you can write it in this convolution
form
um
that
now
okay so that's
yeah like it's one way that it comes up
in applications at least for us and now
convolution has some really nice
property like with respect to the
Fourier transform and and that's let's
start this I'm going to write this as a
preposition
that if I have two function f
then the Fourier transform of their
convolution is just the product of the
two
uh free the the two transforms the
point-wise product so if you know what
the Fourier transform of f is and what
the previous transform of G is then you
can immediately get the free transform
of f convert G that has this nice
property
let's prove this is pretty easy
um
so
that's some character Chi what is this
thing by definition this is the
so let's write
expected value of x now the convolution
is expected value of y
f of x minus y gly so this is just the
convolution at point x
and now I have to multiply this and take
the inner product of this with my
character Chi bar
on X right
so that's just the definition of the
Fourier coefficient I'm taking the inner
product of my function which is this
convolution with the character
okay so now we can just plug in the
Fourier coefficients and expand this
thing
I'm gonna be expected value of x
let's put all the expected values out
and then I'm going to have a sum for
this one and this is
um let's say the characters of this one
and
why and then finally
I can group these things so for
why I'm gonna have five
so this minus y and this Y and for X I'm
gonna have
so that's just everything is equality
right quality is always trivial just
expand it and group these characters
together
now I have these two expected values
which disappeared
expect the value of X and Y here
now because I'm taking these expected
values
[Music]
this is going to be zero unless it's
these are principal characters right so
so when I'm averaging over y the only
way I'm going to get non-zero is if this
is the principal character and the only
way I'm gonna get a non-zero thing here
is if this is the principal characters
so this is the only case the only
surviving terms are gonna be Pi being
the same as PSI being the same as Pi if
if this is not the case uh this term is
gonna disappear when you take the
expected value
so
so these are the only
surviving terms
in that case I'm gonna have the whole
sum is going to be now sum over let's
say
I mean there's no sum anymore it's just
Kai because both of these have to be
equal
so that's
definitely just write this here
right this is clear
foreign
[Music]
okay let me now also Define something
that's gonna come up more in the later
talks which is the noise operator using
convolution
um so here we saw that we're averaging
over this Hamming ball around X but you
you can also average over distributions
you can pick X then modify it randomly
and then average with respect to that
and one natural way is to add coordinate
wise noise so let's say my function is
so back to the cube Z2 to the n
let's say r or c
better and now let's say I want to just
modify each coordinate with some
probability independently
so to do that
let's pick a parameter so Delta is some
number in interval 0 1.
and let me Define a distribution
probability distribution here Mu Delta
application on
to the end
um
defined as follows
I'm going to tell you how to sample
according to Delta which is
foreign
minus Delta over 2
and probably that x i is zero it's going
to be one plus Delta over two and this
is independently
so for each coordinator independent of
this sample it to be one or zero with
this probabilities one minus Delta over
two or and zero with probability one
plus plus so that gives me a
distribution over Z2 to the N which I
denoted by Mu Delta
okay
foreign
so now let's look at this operator which
we call this noise operator T Delta
so this takes a function f and uh
averages it with this noise so it's
gonna tear up T Delta of f it's gonna
map
any point x to
the restricted value of y
f of x plus Y where Y is sampled from
this Mu Delta so what what is happening
here
what is X Plus Delta X Plus y sorry
so let's call this Z so what happens
here is that the probability that z i is
the same as x i is
when when this one is selected to be
zero so that's going to be one plus
Delta over 2
and the probability that this is
corrupted so that I is different from x
i
it's going to be 1 minus Delta over 2
right so it's adding noise to this point
x and averaging over this noise
so
like maybe
yeah better to use y here to be
consistent
okay yeah so here is what we're doing we
pick for any point x we're kind of
averaging x with this noise so over
randomly modifying it and averaging yeah
so here in the notation like Delta
equals zero respond to Pure Noise
exactly so
Delta equals
zero is yeah like pure noise so if Delta
is uh
zero then
then basically we lose our point x right
so this Y is going to be with probably
half one with probability half zero so
like if it doesn't matter what x is it's
just going to be the average of f so
yeah I want directory it's the next
thing I want to say is the two cases of
Delta equals to zero and Delta equals to
one
foreign
this is no noise
the Delta of f in this case
it's just F right so if Delta is one
um I'm always zero
right the probability that M1 is going
to be zero so I'm always zero so I'm
really not changing anything this
expectation becomes exactly f of x
because Y is just going to be always all
zero Vector so this is really just
doesn't change anything and when Delta
is zero then
uh get the Pure Noise
and in this case T Delta of f is just
going to be the
so this is just going to be the uniform
distribution now so your X will be
completely lost so this will be just the
average of it so this is going to be the
constant function which just Maps X
every x to the same number which is the
expected value of f so you get a
constant so you lose all those higher
frequencies what you left is only the
base
uh the extracted value of f
Okay so
I mean it is a very natural thing right
like this definition you just add noise
and you average it
um
so how does this behave in respect to
Fourier expansion
uh quite uh so this
mu that we defined has a really nice
free expansion so
new Delta hat
of s it's pretty easy because coordinate
wise you can do the calculation and
you'll see that this is really just
Delta to the size of s
okay so the free expansion of this
function mu that we Define this is fair
is very straightforward it's just Delta
to the size of s now
then what is when you add noise to your
when you do this noise operator in your
function what do you get
in terms of the free expansion right so
so this is just a convolution of f which
is spoke to this Mu Delta and we know
when you come up you just you're just
multiplying the three coefficients so
you're gonna get a really nice formula
which is
just the sum over s
Delta to the size of s
at path of s kites
so what what happened here is when you
add this noise
um it kind of dampens the higher
frequencies so the larger so let's say
Delta is say one-third or something the
higher values of s get a smaller
coefficient so it kind of starts to kill
higher frequencies and just keep the
lower ones right the the extreme case
when Delta was Zero it kills all the
Fourier coefficients except the
principal one that's why we just got so
this is I should have mentioned it
probably somewhere that expected value
of f is always
there's a different color
write this
um
[Music]
so the principle of free
coefficient so I've had to
zero for any group this is just the
expected value of it
so the average of f is captured by just
one free coefficient and here you see
when Delta is zero it's all the free
coefficients uh
get becomes zero except that one so we
only keep the basic part of f
and this is kind of in a spectrum thing
now for other values of Delta let's say
when Delta is one third you kind of keep
lower ones and then the higher ones get
become smaller and smaller because
you're multiplying this thing that
exponentially grows the Delta to the
size of this
so that's one way of dealing with higher
frequencies often applying this noise
though and it has some nice properties
like hypercontractivity will which will
come up in the later talks
okay so now
I want to move to applications and I
think in the context of theoretical
computer science really the first
application everyone talks about is
linearity testing and I'll do the same
here
foreign
so this is a problem in property testing
and here's the problem I'm giving you a
function which is from Z to to the n
Z2 and I want you to tell me
whether this is a linear function or far
from being linear so case one is
f is linear
meaning that f of x plus y
is the same as f of x plus F of Y this
is mod 2 right in the range now is in Z2
so that's case one case two is
f is
Epsilon far
from being
linear
and what does this mean it means that
for every linear
what we want is that when
if it's
um
doesn't match in on many points
okay so this Epsilon is some parameter
strictly larger than zero
of course
if you want to just tell the difference
between linear and non-linear we really
look at have to look at the point on
every point the function at every point
because you can take a linear function
and just modify it on one point and then
it won't be linear so that's not an
interesting task because like it's just
you have to look at it every point but
here it's uh it's an easier task because
it's kind of a promise problem right
either the function is linear or far
from linear or at least we don't care if
it's close you can make a mistake we
don't care about that so it doesn't
match on many points so yeah so this is
the problem and there's a natural
uh test for it which will come as with
many prop any property testing problem
usually the tests are very easy
and analyzing them is a hard part
Okay so
let's relate this first of all like
before actually giving you the test to
what we've been doing before so let me
Define this other function now
so here the range is Z2 but we've been
doing uh functions where the range is
complex numbers or real numbers so I'm
going to Define this other function f
which is f of x is
minus one two yeah
this is now from Z2 to DN
minus one and one
okay I'm just defining it this way
now what does being linear mean now
foreign
what do I know about f of x plus y it's
going to be minus 1 to the f of x plus F
of Y
which I can write it now as minus 1 to
the F of
let me write
which is minus one of x
which is just f of x times but y okay so
linearity translates to something we've
been looking at which is being a
multiplicative function being a
character so
that is linear
if and only if this capital F is a
character
so
so our problem now is really when we
think about this capital F we want to
know whether it is a character or it's
far from being a character it has some
distance from every character that's uh
so it looks already something that
falls into what we've been looking at
okay so let's look at the natural thing
we would do so this is the test we're
going to perform pick
X and Y
uh random and independently
I'm going to formally
see
all right so we pick two points do the
natural thing so if
f of x plus Y is f of x f of Y
then accept this function as being a
character
else
reject
okay so let's say it's not a character
or it's far from being a character okay
so that's our test and it's really the
most natural thing you can imagine to do
foreign
now let's look at the cases we have so
case one suppose this F is a character
which is the
um
meaning that the small f is a
is linear
so in this case
we're not going to make a mistake right
if if f is actually a character f of x
plus Y is going to be f of x times of f
of Y so we're going to always accept
so no error no mistake here
gonna correctly accept it
the probability one
okay so we are good in this case it's a
one-sided
error situation
now case two is the more interesting
case so in this case
we have this distance thing so we know
we're not only we're not a character but
we're actually far from being a
character so in this case knows that the
probability that f of x
the same as
I have X
um
at least Epsilon and this is for every
character Chi
now let's see what does this tell us
about the free expansion of f
okay so let's write this what is this
probability f of x
so these are one and plus one minus one
valued function so I can write this
probability as this expectation
1 minus expected value of
f of x
over two
right because uh when they are equal I'm
going to get a 1 here and when they are
not equal I'm going to get the negative
one and so if you
look at so it's going to be the
probability that they're equal minus the
probability that they're not equal here
and you get this you have to do this one
minus this divided by two to get the
exact problem
Okay so
but what is this thing this is just the
Fourier coefficient corresponding to Chi
right this is the inner product of f
bank card so this one minus
have had a
divided by two
Okay so
so what we get is that for every
character Chi
this thing is at least Epsilon so
um
it translates to this right so if you
put this is at least Epsilon
you get
and move things around so you get the F
hat of guys at least
so this thing being Epsilon yes two
Epsilon move to the other side you get
one minus two Epsilon
and a part of Pi so none of the free
coefficients are too close to one
what is the linear Case by the way
um so in the linear case this itself was
a character so F was cut some Chi right
so in that case you have one Fourier
coefficient which is one every other
Fourier coefficient is zero so we are
trying to distinguish between two these
two cases one is that you have like all
the Fourier masses on one coefficient
which is one the other case is that all
of them are kind of bounded away from
one so which is this space
okay so that's uh what we know in this
case too but how does that translate to
our test
okay so if you look at our test now
the probability that the test accepts
also we can write it as
one plus
value of f of x plus y
f of x
y
divided by two again something similar
right like if these two things are equal
you get a one here if they're not equal
you get a negative one so uh so if you
look at the probability you get this
formula for it
but this we can write as 1 plus so you
have this convolution here plus and
minus are the same over Z2 to the N so I
can just write that as F convert f of
library
approximate F divided by two
and that gives me
a bit okay so the probability of accept
has a nice formula with respect to free
Acquisitions I can just read it off from
the query coefficient
and I want to say in this case that's
not too close to one so I have some
positive chance of detecting this
and how do you deal with something like
this so
we saw that uh the L2 Norm behaves
pretty nice with Fourier coefficients
right so you can go from physical space
to the previous page but here I have an
L3 Norm it's the sum to the cube so I
can't just say put f of x cubed here
right so I don't have Pi slope for power
three but uh yeah so this is pretty
common that you you extract the L2 part
of it so I can upper bound this by one
plus
so how large can this be if I fix cell
two parts so this is going to be maximum
I apphat of
five times
the L2 part
divided by two okay so this is a pretty
common trick when you're dealing with
three coefficients if you want to bound
things you
yeah you pull out enough maximum so that
you what's your left there is the L2
part now the L2 parties so this is
um now you can do parts of all there so
this is actually one plus
hi
so this is expected value
of x square
multi divided by two now f is taking
only ones and minus ones
so this term is actually one this whole
sum is just one
so I can just drop that from there
continue years not blocked
so that's
equal to one plus Max now
all right so this l21 was one so this I
can just remove this and left with the
max but I know this maximum is
at most one minus two Epsilon so I can
just plug in that there so this is at
most one plus one minus two Epsilon
over two so that's
the
[Music]
one minus
okay so if your function is far away
from being linear
the probability that we are going to
accept is gonna be at most one minus
Epsilon can't be too close to one
okay so so there were two cases right in
the K in case one we won't make a
mistake if it's actually linear we can
accept it in case two if it's far from
linear the probability that we're gonna
make a mistake is also bounded away from
one and because it's one-sided you can
repeat this right so if you're not happy
with one minus Epsilon you can repeat
the test
so log 1 over Epsilon times and you're
gonna improve it to a constant so you
can make it as small as you want right
yeah so it's a very simple it's a good
like first example of application of
these things to the earth called
computer science
yeah and I mean the the whole like we
haven't used really anything other than
the fact that characters are orthogonal
right it's really the whole proof is
just writing things in terms of career
coefficients and using door technology
and things cancel
okay questions about this
right
um
okay so something that came up here in
this proof you see the kind of
like factored out this maximum Fourier
coefficient
uh and
like when you were dealing with this
kind of expectation this maximum free
coefficient kind of we could use it to
bound it make it small so this leads to
this notion of pseudorandomness uh which
again comes up a lot in uh I mean
there's all these prg studies in
computers interactive computer science
also in additive combinatorics when you
study sets you often divide between sets
that look random and
and the sets that are structured
okay so let me Define this uh be more
clear I'm talking about
so F let's call F let's just say
function from
actually this is for the dude for
General agreement groups
Epsilon
random
if all the non-principal Fourier
coefficients about are small
so F hat of chi
is less than Epsilon for all
non-principled pre-approvision the
principle one is just the average of f
so in this case we'll forgive that one
if f is a dense set and the average
expected value is large
we I mean
um it's fine we really care about
non-principle Fourier coefficients here
right so when you write the free
expansion of f you have the first term
the principal one is the just the
expected value of F and the rest are
these three coefficients and we want all
of those other free coefficients to be
small
um
so
I want to show you something that looks
very similar to this proof but it's
about say three-term economic
progressions
foreign
let's do
CP for example I can do any Group G
such that
the expected value or
size of a
and the size of the group p and my
function the indicator function of this
is Epsilon
okay so this is my setting I have a
subset of GP and I it looks kind of
random according to this definition so
all the three coefficients of the
indicator function are small so again
one of a if this notation I'm using just
Maps X to one
uh if x is in a
zero X is not
the notation uh I'm interested in
counting the number of say three-term
arithmetic progressions in a so let's
look at that
and I'll count it in a normalized way so
what I'm going to do is
I'll pick a random X for my starting
point and the length of the step a
random y
and now look at what is the probability
that X is in a
X Plus Y is in a
and X Plus 2y is in there right so this
is a three-term arithmetic progression
that's fully in a
uh its starting point is in a it's next
point is an A and last point is
let's write this and see what we can
say about this using this Fourier
uh expansion
okay so what we do in these situations
we just replace our function with this
free expansion right so what you're
gonna get now is
uh expected value of x expected value of
y and I have three copies of my function
and for each one I'm plugging in it's
free expansion
so I'm gonna have these three sums here
so this is some Chi
okay I have this just replace each copy
of this 1A with its free expansion and
now I can just distribute these sums
okay
foreign
X
okay so yeah
foreign
now again very similar to what we had
before
we have to look at these terms these
expected values for different characters
of like triples or characters sci-fi uh
chi PSI pi
so when is that let's try to understand
that expected value so I can again use
the fact that these are characters and
regroup them so this just this part
equals to
respect the value of X and Y
then I'm going to get
I
thought X
and then times
um
so
again so this thing when is it not zero
so I'm gonna have
maybe yeah I've been
so
they've been easier if I use the index
notation but I guess it's fine
so I have these two characters here this
one and this one so again this expected
value is zero the only surviving term
so the only
so I'm gonna have to have that this is
by
conjugates to make this the principal
character and once I have that
plug that here so and the other case
which is all right PSI Y which if I plug
that here
I'm gonna have
me zero which means
same
Okay so
I mean these are just two characters and
I need both of them to be zero because
I'm averaging over X and Y if they're
not zero this whole
expectation gonna be zero and this one
tells me that PSI and fire related like
if I know what's pi is I'm going to know
what size and if I plug into that one
here I'm gonna also know that
um Cayenne file also supposed to be the
same
so
yeah so now I can write this whole sum
as sum over let's say
let's write number five this is going to
be
yeah I
this one is
so instead of this triple sum I ended up
with just sum over one character because
it's one of them has to determine the
other ones otherwise they all disappear
okay so this average which kind of
counts the number of three dramatic
regressions it also counts the boring
ones right y could be zero here which is
X repeated several times
um
uh has a nice formula in terms of the
free Appropriations I can write it this
way
now what do I know about my function I
know that it's Epsilon to the random so
I know that when this thing is non-zero
these are small
under zero case it's just the density of
the set it's expected value of 1A so I'm
going to separate that so this is going
to be the first case where Phi is zero
so that's just Alpha Cube
plus the case where Phi is not the zero
character
yeah I just separated
one term where this Pi was the zero
principle character so that gives me
Alpha Cube
and then the rest is just the other
characters now what can I say about the
sum how do I bound it it's magnitude
using this pseudorandomeness
yeah
I found the last term by Epsilon and
then use a drone exactly so again we can
do the same thing we did here so just
pull out say the last term which is at
most Epsilon and then the rest is just
the sum
so
thank you
this expected value that we're
interested X and Y
EP
why right
how far can it be from alpha Cube so
that's this term and that I can Bound by
maximum uh over say
or
arms to sum
and so this we know from the pseudor
randomness property we know this thing
is at most Epsilon right so we have a
bound
using this definition of Epsilon
I think
yeah
so that is at most
Epsilon times this thing is
going to write this as expected value on
a way
but minus
so I will remove the the
zero case which is that's just the
average of a
like uh I mean what I want to say you
can bound this more in terms of say
Alpha but just Epsilon is good enough
for us
um okay
so what does this show us it shows that
if if the set is kind of random looking
then the number of pre-term arithmetic
progression kind of corresponds it's
close to what you see for a random set
right if a was a completely random set
of density Alpha then this expectation
would be around Alpha Cube and you you
get this thing too
um okay
five minutes what can I say
um
yeah
so one thing so the large three
coefficients are important as you can
see it here right like they control some
stuff and if they're if all of those
three coefficients are small then we get
the set behaves in a pan away and one
important thing that comes up is to
understand where these large query
coefficients can be so for that you can
Define this notion which is spectral
Epsilon of f so this is the set of all
um
okay such that
at least
um
I'll Define it with
some function say from
okay so these are the large three
coefficients so you get you look at
where they they are so those characters
are
larger than just because we're doing Z2
to the analogy actually is the chi
estimation
yeah
now how large can this set be so that's
like the first question let us ask this
um by Percival I know
some of all the squares of the three
coefficients this is just the expected
value of x squared but this is because f
is Boolean this is the same as expected
value of f
which is let's denote this by Alpha
so the whole sum is at least Alpha but
now let's see how much these large ones
contribute here
um
on the other hand I can lower bound this
thing right so sum up hepatitis
squared
this is at least the size of this set
that's
times
now each one of these characters that
are here they're contributing at least
Epsilon Alpha Square to this sum
right because they're at least Epsilon
Alpha so you square them contribute this
much
so what we get is
that
that's more at most Alpha divided by
right
now
okay so you can't have too many of these
large query coefficients in this sense
they're at most one over Alpha Epsilon
Square
um yeah but uh I mean the next thing I
wanted to say but I don't have time to
really to prove it is uh
so this is a very useful Lemma that uh
comes up in a lot of applications which
says this set is not
even though it can be that large it can
be an arbitrary set so you have you're
going to have some structure in this set
it's called Chang's Lemma
says
the
dimension of if you if you take this set
I mean we are in the Dual Group which is
also Z2 to the end so you can look at
the linear span of this set
this is at most
logo the one over
times
Square so even though the size of the
set is related in terms of alpha it's
like 1 over Alpha but in terms of
Dimension it lives in a lower Dimension
space so it's uh the dependency you're
going to get is log so I don't have time
to prove this that that's the reason I
plan for this is that
you can prove this directly using
concentration
uh of measures kind of simple proof but
you can also prove it to be with Hyper
contractivity so that would be also a
good application of hyperconductivity
for later uh but yeah I think I'll just
stop here so this is a use like it comes
up a lot in applications added to
combatorex because you you often have to
deal with these large free coefficients
and it tells you that they live in this
low dimensional space so you can extract
them you can pick those that low damage
from space and get some structure about
your set using that
um okay so that's all I had planned for
the lectures if you have questions
that's good
that is about what uh
I'm trying to get assistance for what
parameters you can use this for so like
could you use this to try and understand
like a
um
I could use it to use like understand
the Epsilon bicep like let's say you
knew all of them were pretty small but
then maybe you wanted to know well okay
well which ones are at least like
Epsilon over two or something
what what parameters is the most
influenced
so I have increased it and that's
applied in life to understand central
island sets but it's more of the
applications are more in uh commenters
when you have to set a and you know say
the count of say some linear structure
in it is
uh it's up and you want to get some
Subspace where the set like do some
density increment or something and when
you want to bound the dimension of that
Subspace you look at these three
coefficients and
that you kind of find where they
disappears so you define the cell space
correct that so again dependencies that
are logarithmic to the density of your
set that's true
but
okay
yeah
just what's the difference between the
size of the spectrum and the dimension
of this
yeah so
right so these are you look at the
characters as
uh
so they live in a group right and the
group is isomographic to Z to the end so
you look at them as elements of this
group not so yeah so it's like really a
subset of Z to the n and we look at the
linears
not overreals
okay
so thank you again
we have St but this will be at 2 pm
Sharp